Support for big thing comes from
Microsoft delivering people ready
enterprise solutions designed to help
companies do more with less details at
Microsoft.com/people ready.
I'm Tom Stemberg.
I'm the managing general partner of the
highland consumer funds.
Without question.
A lot of entrepreneurial ideas come out
of challenging times.
I always say that entrepreneurs are
folks who turned adversity into
opportunity.
A good example of that is right now in
the retail space,
and I tend to vest in the retail space,
you can finally afford to open units in
Manhattan.
Again,
over the past decade,
rents were so absurd that unless you had
ridiculous price points at obscene gross
margins,
you couldn't possibly afford to pay the
rent.
Well,
that's changed very dramatically over
the last 12 months.
And that's unbalanced.
I think a good thing.
Uh,
and we will see lots of great ideas
spawned out of this downturn.
Engineers who get laid off from big
companies are going to start new
companies and those kinds of companies
are going to change things going into
the future.
A,
B,
they in communications between energy
and be they in lots of other areas.
Uh,
first of all,
obviously those entities which are
positioned as value brands will do
better than those who are perceived as
high price or,
or having frills to them.
So to be clear you want to be there,
but having said that,
what you don't want to do is begin to
move away from your fundamental brand
position,
just kind of as a temporary fix during a
downtime.
So what we've seen lots of people do a
is during these times say,
well,
you know,
I'm brand x and would I create something
called kind of brand x and where they
used to sell brand decks to full price
retailers and now so it kind of brand x
to Walmart and Costco.
And then what happens is the full price
full service retail say I'm not going to
do business with these guys anymore.
And next thing you know,
they basically destroyed their entire
brand equity.
And that's happened too often.
So you got to be very careful and
sticking to what your brand stands for
in the consumer's mind.
Well,
the generic brands were an outgrowth of
the Jimmy Carter stagflation years where
the economy was declining.
And we combine that with a high double
digit,
almost 20 percent interest rates.
Uh,
fortunately we don't face that today,
uh,
the but inflation was running rampant
and I got to be very clear with you that
I did not invent generic brands.
I copied them if company in France
called cuff for a,
had created something called Lipo which
were so called free products,
free from advertising free from
expensive marketing,
just the fundamentalist.
Uh,
my boss at jewel,
a gentleman named Don Perkins,
saw this in Europe and brought it back
to his company is say,
guys,
you got to try this.
And some of the,
the divisions and the bigger divisions
didn't want to run with the idea because
they were worried it would cannibalize
their private label at lower margins,
etc.
I was the head of marketing at star
market in boston where we had a very
high quality of but a high price
reputation.
I said,
this is a big idea that if we
entrepreneurially move forward to this,
we could change our price perception
overnight.
A,
therefore we copied it,
that we rebranded it.
No name brands.
[inaudible] a great low cost restaurant
in boston called the no name and we
figured we live off that we call the no
name brands and uh,
it turned out to be an overnight success
and we didn't have to advertise it
because we,
all the news media climbing all over it
and the prices are so dramatically low
what it took care of itself and was a
very interesting venture that overtime
kind of,
you know.
Uh,
so it's time come and go.
Well,
I think there's a couple things that I'd
say as I reflect back on my staples
career and gosh,
there's lots of things I'm incredibly
proud of having done,
including giving us a leadership
position on the internet.
One I'm less proud of is how we approach
international because frankly we
approached international too soon.
Uh,
Canada was,
was worked out well and that was early
in.
It's close enough.
That worked out great.
If you go through the historical profit
and loss statements,
not today,
But how they used to be a 10 years ago
or so in 15 years ago in Germany and
england,
and is not a pretty picture.
It's extremely hard to take any kind of
people intensive business from the
United States over to europe and you
know,
for all our economic problems,
I'd argue there's are worse than ours.
I mean with their pension obligations
and the union structures.
I think actually they have more problems
than we do and we got plenty of problems
so that the notion you somehow another
find growth and prosperity in europe and
it's easy or that england is easy
because they speak the same language.
It is just not true.
And uh,
I had a colleague at staples named joe
vessel.
So what a,
what a great line.
He quoted churchill and saying in
england and the us were two countries
divided by a common language in the
example and england when they were
forced to turnover,
that means revenues is a good thing.
We talked about turnover here in the
states.
It's a bad thing.
I think that indian China harbor nola as
difficulties from an expansion for
interview than england,
Germany arguably they're even more
difficult.
Having said that,
the good news about england,
about China and India is you've got
explosive growth and growth covers on
awful lot of sins.
So even with the chinese growth
moderating,
it's moderating to still be amongst the
fastest,
if not the fastest growing economy in
the world.
Uh,
we had terrific success there with
staples were invested in the business
that's now grown to be a several hundred
million dollar business.
And uh,
I've got lots of friends over there and
uh,
so I still see tremendous opportunities
there,
particularly in the consumer segment and
in retailing.
We see lots of opportunities in China,
India,
uh,
I would characterize it similarly.
So having said that,
the,
uh,
if you're a software business,
it's probably easier if you're in the
retail business.
The challenge of dIstribution over there
and the fact there's not really road
patterns over there.
Uh,
I think it makes it very,
very challenging.
I think the first thing I would advise
any chief executive entering these
times,
and I think interestingly in this time
around,
you didn't have to advise the ceos,
the good ones.
People like Christine Day,
a little lemon or tommy folio at carmax
or fill francis at petsmart,
didn't have to be told.
They on their own realized that they had
to prepare their companies for what
could be a calamitous situation.
You just didn't know how bad it was
going to get and in virtually every case
they planned for scenarios that turned
out to be far worse than at least we've
seen to date.
Having done that in first and foremost
have insured survival.
That's your first job.
Once you've gotten to that point and now
you see sort of the dust settle and I'm
an optimist,
so I think that does more or less has
settled.
Then you now have to become
opportunistic very quickly and you
almost have to turn it a hundred and 80
degrees and I see these companies now
are poisoned themselves to grow.
But Christine Day was in New York half
of lulu lemon about a week ago and
that's very,
very exciting company and she came in
and basically said to the landlords
know,
gentlemen,
if you follow the following guidelines
we have for a new leases going forward,
we're now prepared to look at
opportunities.
But if you still have some of these
crazy red ideas that came about,
uh,
at the beginning of the century,
at the end of the last one,
just hold onto your property and we'll,
we'll,
we'll just walk by those for lease
signs.
Support for big thing comes from
microsoft delivering people ready
enterprise solutions designed to help
companies do more with less details at
microsoft.com/people ready.